Congratulations.
You've learned a lot of tools
to solve computational problems.
Now we're going to dive into some of the
most well-known computational problems,
and see how we can use
our tools to solve them.
Along the way, we'll look at
a few famous algorithms and
concepts that show up often
on technical interviews.
You might not get asked
specifically to solve one of these
problems in an interview.
But it's common to be presented with a
problem that boils down to one of these.
Make sure you have a crystal clear
understanding of the root problem.
And stay vigilant for instances of
these cases masked as something else.